la nouvelle famille on l'a trouvé dans
les bagages ce que à nous a apporté ça a
dépassé tout çà c'est même plus palpable
ces voix là c'est le coeur
lotta d'accord ok pour toi une tatie
super génial margot diagnostiqué d'un
cancer doit être soigné à paris au
centre gustave roussy toute la famille
basé à cayenne en guyane des ménages en
france désorienté alexandra a trouvé un
véritable soutien auprès de anne
fondatrice de l'association les bagouzes
amman ont créé il y a dix sept ans suite
au décès de sa fille atteinte d'un
cancer avant qu'on parte pour les vannes
sur gustave roussy on m'a donné le
contact de l'association en disant
vraiment elle peut
anne peut t'aider dans te dire ce qui
convient de faire dans les orientations
elle est passée par là donc elle pourra
vraiment te conseiller sur ou allez quoi
faire etc sachant très bien qu'à paris
pas de famille pas d'amis pas de soutien
et dont ben tout contact tout relais est
bon à prendre parce qu'on sait pas de
quoi demain sera fait en 2005 anne
décide de commencer à récolter de
l'argent pour financer la recherche
contre les cancers de l'enfant elle vend
alors les bacs qu'elle fabriqué avec sa
fille à l'hôpital et fonde son
association les bagouzes amano
aujourd'hui l'association compte une
vingtaine de bénévoles et a récolté près
de 600000 euros quand j'ai créé
l'association est à 17 ans je disais
toujours c'est un moyen de faire vivre
ma non c'est elle qui m'a insufflé toute
cette force et toute cette envie de
soutenir la recherche bat pour faire
qu'on puisse arriver aux résultats que
l'on a aujourd'hui avec margot qui est
en rémission parce que le cancer qu'elle
a se guérit très bien à l'occasion de la
journée internationale des cancers de
l'enfant l'association organise une
soirée le samedi 5 février dans la salle
l'ariana vélizy-villacoublay
100% des fonds collectés seront reversés
au profit de la recherche sur les
cancers de l'enfant